aveva 23 anni
stanza di tutto il paese quella speranza
che corre dietro a un pallone
tutti parlavano di lui e tutti parlavano
del paese aveva solo 23 anni
il paese molti di più genius loci genius
loci così finiva ogni domenica il
predicozzo di padre baldassarre il
momento più atteso
unica deroga al sacro protocollo che
teneva inchiodati fedelissimi degli
agonizzanti il genere altrove la gloria
lo attendeva tutto il paese parlava di
lui e tutti parlavano del paese
anche padre baldassarre ne parlava si
attendeva e si sperava quell'attesa e
quella speranza che corrono dietro un
pallone in paese non calava mai
l'oscurità al bar in farmacia al
tabacchi dal vero durare anche al santo
spirito
sembrava di stare sempre alla festa del
crocifisso
c'era un gran traffico di carusi con il
ginocchio maciullati tutti a correre
dietro un pallone si diceva che gli
infermieri non facessero alcuna fatica a
ricucire più recalcitrante le
rassicurazioni di rito erano cosa da
vecchi mestieranti scattava conforto il
conto sul genio lui ce l'aveva fatta
senza chianti per un ginocchio
maciullata aveva solo 23 anni
il paese molti di più un genio lo tiri
su a pane cv da questo franca e rosario
stavano bene stesso companatico per gli
altri cinque mascolini sulle quantità ce
l'ha fatta qualche differenza senza ma
ogni tanto in dialoghi franca il rosario
a fare le cose giuste ci tenevano tutti
uguali sono altrimenti non si cominciano
a mangiarlo
certo qualcosa andò storto o forse è
così che va la vita un genio lo teso ma
gli altri cinque che fine fanno
è uscito fuori razza angelo fuori orario
non assimilano così si diceva in paese
tutti mangiano pareggi food tutti
parlavano di lui e tutti parlavano nella
famiglia un traffico continuerà con la
casa non calava mai l'oscurità tutta per
gli album del genio la curiosità a
nessuno interessava il corredo franca il
rosario avevano sofferto se non ha
sposati senza a muccione di nascosto una
foto dietro l'altra
diciamola come si fa con i piedi e santi
un predestinato a qualcuno la
lacrimuccia scendeva mai a sapere se per
colpa dell ac food
cosa peraltro più nobile ragione un
traffico continuerà con la casa anche
padre baldassarre ci passava non senza
un pizzico di invidia
se ne tornava altro companatico lui sì
che aveva studiato faceva sempre il
pieno ai agonizzanti ma quel genio
funzionava più della pro loco e dei
santi il paese viveva uno stato di
grazia
torino manchester siviglia monaco le
gioie da fuori arrivavano e tutti ci
stavano dentro oppure quelli mai
maritati gli zoppi e l'ultima guerra e
quelli del boom economico
le sentinelle la piazza ei annoiate
l'ufficio tecnico il nume tutelare
tutelava e garantiva garantiva e
tutelava tutti aveva solo 23 anni
il paese molti di più non
dimentichiamocelo
ma lo stato di grazia e fatto
transitorio accidente effimera in un
paese sgraziato e disgraziata oppure
così che va la vita dono calato dal
cielo senza intercessione divina
insperata certificazione di qualità
l'altra faccia della mobilità al
miramare accidente o meno ti capitava di
dividere lo stesso caffè con il figlio e
l'avvocato il primo di sam ascoli di
tutti impostati un saluto come si
conviene un cenno di intesa per dirsi
siamo tutti uguali
il figlio e l'avvocato conosceva le
carte
perché mai doveva correre dietro un
pallone
la grazia senza piccioli si consuma
prima dei cieli degli agonizzanti ei
piccoli arrivano insieme ai turisti agli
americani e francesi pure gli emigranti
tornare il genere altrove è più una
lontana e più funzionava funzionava più
della pro loco
lo abbiamo detto fatele baldassar per
pressioni ricevute non si pronunciava fa
di miracolo si trattava non senza un
pizzico di invidia lo pensava si
potrebbe continuare così
ma il vento cambia senza intercessione
divina ci mancherebbe
giunse notizia che più storta non poteva
essere il nostro genio il ginocchio si
masullo incidente serissimo non
intervenuto nell'esercizio abilissimo
delle sue funzioni ma accidente
domestico non meglio specificato il
dottore perfezione ricevute non si
pronuncia ma di ritiro prematuro si
trattava tornava a fare scuro in paese
quello scuro che non fai fatica a
chiamare lutto oppure che non aveva i
capelli si teneva la testa e quando una
notizia fa acqua da tutte le parti
nell'oscurantismo trova facile riparo
tutta colpa di una femmina
così si diceva in paese non senza un
pizzico di malignità dal genio non
giunse più notizie pure del nonno non si
era saputo più niente ma anche la
cartolina dalla russia prigioniero di
guerra o di una femmina gli annoiati
nell'ufficio tecnico e non solo loro per
la verità andavano dicendo che avesse
militato oppure nella squadra dei
ferrovieri quelli picciriddi si
lanciavano altro che ci punte lokomotiv
così lo chiamavano in paese torna
l'inverno quell'inverno che non finisce
mai
l'umido disincanto fa capolino ti entra
nelle ossa non ci possono nemmeno i
santi del genere non giunse più notizie
come del nonno stessa cosa gli americani
dei francesi degli emigranti che li ha
più visti
il certificato di qualità revocato per
fine anno
lo stato di grazia evaporato come un
sogno allucinato può vivere un paese
senza genius loci nullus locus fine
genio
nessun luogo e senza un genio tutti
accor indietro e tutti a sbatterci la
francia al primo ginocchio ha mancato di
stucco erano rimasti come tutti degli
agonizzanti il pozzo sarà rideva e
niente poteva ritiro prematuro sentenza
senza ritorno non possiamo certo
scomodare lo sconforto con la parola
tiri fuori per un figlio perso come le
lenzuola di pizzo macramè dal comò prima
di sgravarlo questo lo sapevano bene
anche franca il rosario
tornano a fare la spesa a dormire come i
cristiani le foto sconsacrate rimesse
dove stavano di scomparsa apparente si
trattava quella che non ti consegna al
mito ma alla dimenticanza trascorsa
altro tempo difficile dire quanto le
sentinelle la piazza avevano altro da
guardare che l'orologio del campanile lo
spilungone stava lì forse da sempre chi
se ne curava era roba da cartolina o
buono per farci l'ombra i cani da
vendere pochi turisti rimasti con
quattro parole accompagnate così
sgrammaticate da far rizzare il pelo
pure i gatti che insieme ai cani
all'ombra del campanile se ne stavano a
sant'anna la fermata dell'autobus non
c'era più ora ci metteva il macchinone
il figlio e l'avvocato stava al primo
piano nelle cose buone si era maritate
voleva stare tranquillo faceva pure
l'assessore il paese rimaneva lì dove
l'avevamo lasciato chiunque avesse
voluto poteva vederlo e toccarlo
solo chi possedeva l'aveva fatto con
occhio losco e in mano pesante come il
cemento armato trascorse altro tempo
difficile dire quanto era passato il
tempo dei orbi congrega di cantori e
suonatori di conti e cantastorie di
cartelloni pittati e trionfi della
parola detta e ridetta urbi et orbi del
gene di suo nonno locomotiv manco
l'ombra
le chip udine potevamo cramant
ma solo con gli hamburger la mostarda
a pensarci bene se interrogati tutti si
pronunciano una per la tradizione lo
spirito del luogo i vecchi valori
perduti traditi
ecco traditi ma da chi a qualcuno
lacrimuccia scendevo ma è sapere se per
colpendoci punto con gli hamburger e la
mostarda o se per altra nobile ragione
la nostalgia aveva il suo packaging
formato famiglia 10 x 15 un paese
cartolina solo figuravano così e così lo
volevano questo la pro loco lo sapeva
bene e non faceva altro che stampare
cartoline un paese di orbi era diventato
oppure a vederci meglio forse la vera
sempre stato
si potrebbe continuare così ma il vento
cambia ancora una volta una sera di
luglio
lo scirocco assediava case e chiese e
magazzini incursione saracena tradimento
il kamarina sembra piegarsi in due per
rifiatare
l'orologio si fece un giro tutto suo non
c'era anima viva
cani e gatti non siamo fatti vedere per
tutto il giorno
l'indomani le sveglia si attivarono a
loro piacimento
e intanto la notizia già di primo
mattino vorticava per tutti gli angoli
del paese
le cartoline non ci sono più scomparsa
nella notte migliaia di cartoline i più
audaci accusarono sciroppo di furore
iconoclasta tutti gli altri
sentenziarono che di furto in piena
regola si trattava è subito sollecitano
le autorità a spicciarsi per riparare a
con infamia il paese si svegliò senza un
volto quello rassicurante di una
cartolina non si vedeva tanto movimento
sulle parate della piazza dal funerale
del padre baldassarre comitato da una
parte e dall'altra il sindaco che non
sapeva dove sbattersi prima con quella
fascia che al posto suo non ci voleva
stare assessori e consiglieri due passi
indietro ma un funerale del padre
baldassarre tutti intenzionati a
risolvere quell'amaro caso perché si
pensi quello che si vuole ma ci tenevamo
tutti a non perdere la faccia a qualcuno
venne pure gli ideali della destra di
cani alla b
sogno ma quelli anche per quel giorno
non si fecero vedere ai gatti non ci
pensa nessuno trascorsa alto tempo
quello necessario per arrivare alla
verità dei fatti commissari comitati e
uomini di buona volontà non si
distinsero per intuito e perizie si
affannavano annaspavano senza una
precisa direzione come prezzi dallo
scirocco sfuggiva il motivo il movente
però se la parola giusta
voci non ufficiali e sempre più
insistenti stringevano nel cerchio
attorno a un gruppo di balordi si diceva
che avessero costituito una repubblica
lunga e larga quanto un vicolo cieco è
che fossero protetti al fantasma di una
femmina in quel budello faceva la vita è
una strada giustizia un giorno se la
porto via per sempre
caterina si chiamava nessuna cartolina
ricordava un serafino il più alto è il
più bello del coro del primo ordine
assetato di giustizia e carità con due
ali avvolse e con gli altri quattro in
paese era di porto sì ma in tutto questo
cosa c'entra quei balordi con le
cartoline c'entravano a como quei
balordi con le cartoline ci costringa
una locomotiva si una locomotiva una
locomotiva di carta ferma in un vicolo
cieco
le vecchie icone è volata via con lo
scirocco ora bisognava attendere i
viaggiatori per sentirla sbuffa nuovi
viaggiatori pro loco moti così la
chiamavano in paese
prima di congedarmi da voi è mia premura
farvi avere i saluti di zio carmelo
lui alla kermesse non ci ha abituato
avrebbe provato un certo imbarazzo
altro aspetto di una platea così
numeroso e quindi faccio io
arrivati a questo punto con fare
risoluto seduto al tavolo avrebbe fatto
un po di spazio davanti a se da una
parte il pane dall'altra le cipolle e
avrebbe detto se esiste cos'è questo
benedetto spirito di un luogo è qualcosa
di impalpabile che si perde nella notte
dei tempi di immutabile per sua natura
un divenire carico di conseguenze
impreviste o un elisir di giovinezza e
prosperità
o ancora una rappresentazione univoca e
fedele dell'immagine di un luogo di una
comunità ma supponiamo che esista per
davvero
va preservato e difeso promosso e da chi
di chi ci fidiamo a chi affidiamo i
nostri sguardi ai consulenti per le
immagini agli esperti nella promozione
di un territorio al ministero della
cultura ha un assessorato o un'app ai
volontari a un artista esaurito l'elenco
zio carmelo
si sarebbe atteso l'alto e ci avrebbe
lasciati senza una risposta è quella
risposta io non ce l'ho
ho una locomotiva che mi parte tra dieci
minuti e quindi qui vi lascio con i miei
saluti e con cui lo zio carmelo e vi
ringrazio
[Applauso]